gender reveals you ever seen one of
these ken
never never
i hope to never see one in real life
because there's nothing more cringe than
a gender reveal party so you never had
one
no oh i made the mistake of making a
joke in one video about how i thought we
may have had one and mary like walked in
the room after watching the video be
like why would you say that
how could you there's nothing wrong with
gender evil because today i'm gonna
prove it we're gonna check out some
hilarious i mean some amazing wholesome
gender reveals
nothing bad ever happens
[Applause]
oh poor look chad got it all in his
mouth you gotta close in his nose
[Applause]
it's a boy congratulations
take it out man taking the boy out of it
i already hate him he's covering his
ears
he was gonna be loud
the boy is just like
i like how he just doesn't care that the
boy is like right next to it look at
this like a big puff of like crap right
there about him in the face if this is
me i'd be like i'm not cleaning that up
can we at least pop it outside and then
someone else's garden before we continue
quick word from sponsor exciting new
announcement we got another collab with
rhinoshield if you're looking to make
your phone absolutely indestructible
like a nokia 3310 rhino shield's got you
baby i've tested these myself scythe
show the clip
oh no
stronger than stone i highly recommend
these so yeah we're launching a new
collection with a sought out clear cases
this looks god damn good
let's test this out um one of you guys
the other day and she was like oh that
could have been bad i didn't have the k
song yet maya is assisting me with this
promo
want to say hi maya
so yeah i met one of you guys the other
day and she whipped up the same phone
case as i had it was awesome anyway
also thank you ryan [ __ ] for being
responsible with your packing we
appreciate it i gotta change mine
some of the finest designers over at
rhino shield they really nail these i
love them they always turn out super
cool yeah looking good
what i really love about these is that
you can customize them you can change
these these buttons
you can change the framing
in all kinds of colors i love that i
don't wear you guys but i love being
able to customize and these are just
really cool really sturdy cases so we
have four new designs the basic one this
one uh they're available for almost any
flagship phone i mean i have a kind of
an empty phone as well so and we got
this one looking nice
zero there's baby a big problem with
that clear cases is that they kind of
turn yellow after a while but they solve
this issue rhino shield they have made a
uv exposure simulation let me see it
[Music]
so other brands will uh fade and in
quality over time they'll turn yellow
and gooey and disgusting looking
while rhino shield stands the test of
time which is uh yeah just another
example of that it is a legitimately
quality product we have this one as well
obviously they have attack on titan i'll
show more in a bit the most important
thing we of course got the classic clear
case as well and due to popular demand
we brought back tokyo knights
very clean i am so paranoid about losing
my phone you have no idea i got
everything
that matters to me
in my phone so i saw that they announced
that doing these uh
stripes for them i was [ __ ] excited
not only do they look good
i can feel good knowing my phone is safe
around my neck and not having that panic
is it in my
is it in my pocket is it in this pocket
is my in the pocket is it this pocket
this is
[Applause]
someone call my phone right now
oh oh my my bad here it is
oh what's that i got the pewdiepie case
oh yeah looks [ __ ] good man god damn
check this out check it out check it out
don't look at my pp check it out
that's the nicest one so far i think we
got so yeah these straps come in
different colors as well they have a ton
of stuff but yeah these clear cases
looking fire though not gonna lie
uh check them out link is in the
description we got a great deal for you
so these bad boys ship worldwide
wherever you are you got no excuse in
case i bump into you and ask hey what
phone case you got hey you want selfie
with me yeah i'm joking by the way it's
a joke but yeah this [ __ ] worldwide and
there's actually free shipping for
qualified orders and lifetime warranty
for these bad boys that's how much they
believe in their quality and i got a
great deal for you guys fair deal if you
enter discount code pewdiepie you get 20
up but only in the first week so make
sure you do it now and don't forget to
enter the code pewdiepie on the checkout
you know uh they also have attack on
titan
keith herring he's cool and other
amazing collaborations worth checking
out pewdiepie being the only one you
really need let's get real here but oh
yeah this one's cool too it's not even
mine i actually like it so yeah maybe
you're in case you're one of those
people that's like yeah i guess i like
pewdiepie's video i want to support him
by entering the code pewdiepie but do i
want to have his phone case yes i do yes
you want look how cool that is that's
[ __ ] cool you can't say that's not
cool anyway that's a long promo but it's
a cool offer and i'm really proud of it
so uh yeah thanks for for sticking
through it i guess
all right that was that was not that bad
but it will get worse wait are we
supposed to be proven that gender rival
parties aren't bad yes that seemed
the baby was fine
[Laughter]
[Applause]
a little kiss before that's cute
what is it it's all genders
yay
i feel like this is a stage what the
what's the daughter what
what
shocked mom oh we gotta post his own
tick tock so everyone sees what a fail
oh what a fail don't post it guys we're
so embarrassed what company sells boxes
of balloons yeah how would these
possibly happen even the babies like
yeah i'm not impressed this is suspect
[Laughter]
aren't parents nowadays i mean you can
correct me aren't they trying to move
away from the whole gender stereotypes
with pink and blue yeah yeah i mean i
think that's always been a
goal right is let your kid be who they
want to be uh-huh not my chime
oh yeah yeah cleaning
cleaner i could indoctrinate my child to
just become like a butler for me or
something
it's not the goal what is your gender
butler
hang on a minute why why why does your
child have to enter this world and
eventually
immediately
should exist to serve me
i made it come to existence i need
something out of this transaction
we got a long history of discussions
about children you want to feed them dog
food
yeah
so the thing seems fair if they don't
know any better if you teach your child
that dog food is good then that's the
ultimate they would be happier too and
then imagine then one day when they
discover real food they'll be like wow
this is amazing and i'll be like what
are you gonna do i gave you that
experience enjoyed it
with like a broom no no not real food
get that out of your mouth this is all
the concept of like if you're grown up
with little and then experience more
later that's more satisfying but if you
grow up with a lot you never satisfy so
therefore give child nothing
become butler
ultimate success story i think people
will read about this in the future whoa
so the perfect life the key to like the
happiest life you could ever live is
like have literally nothing your entire
life
on your death bed they just hit you with
every experience right at once and you
have a heart attack like excitement
yeah
moving on
maybe this baby will like rake the
leaves or something after this this is
pathetic look at this yard yeah yeah
make the baby do it we were taught in
school to break leaves
all right i was indoctrinated as well
they made us do it it was fun i thought
it was fun see how deep in my mind they
were
they can't even put the card back in
there we don't even know
we don't even know
wait so it's the point that none of the
parents knew i always thought one of the
parents knew yeah usually someone knows
that like sets up the whole party right
right
[Music]
yay
do you see this shot in the nuts
hold up replay
oh
that'll be the last one he has
it doesn't hit him in the nuts
i'm sorry guys oh maybe maybe if he did
the tuck they all tucked to the side
he put in his pocket
oh okay hold on a minute
look at him he's faking it
they didn't even hit there
oh no
no you're breaking it why would you do
that oh
my god
why would they do this why
it's supposed to be the reveal that's
blue on the inside wow incredible what a
fun review
they just ruined the cupcake how could
they i guess that's the thing with these
parties is that everyone wants to come
up with their own formula instead of
someone picking one thing that works
everyone's like nah what we're going to
do is we're going to get a helicopter
that explodes
and the color of the flames will
like everyone just pick one thing right
and then california burns down i think
california burns down yeah we're gonna
destroy this cupcake in front of the
child so she cries and the tears the
color of the tears different
hue will
oh the children always have to suffer
the parents are like oh they're gonna be
so excited then they're just like well i
just want to eat that cupcake
are you a [ __ ] gender
yeah you're right
four kids
you're gonna have a brother they say it
too this is some deep psychological
thing where like they'll hate their
brother subconsciously for a whole life
they're like i don't get it i don't
understand why i hate my brother he's
super nice to me but that one time in
therapy they clicks the cuff cake
i know this is a good one
[Music]
it feels in front of a baseball
what are you doing
[Applause]
look at that close-up shot i have darwin
awards on these parents man [ __ ]
it's a girl
classic balloon child
[Applause]
suffering
[Music]
it's a good old box again with dots on
it what was supposed to happen
whoever this company is they need to be
stopped they're out of control
who keeps buying for them
uh oh baby as it oh my god stop hurting
the kids why why the children suffer
if it's blue you're gonna have a baby
brother
if it's pink you're going to have a baby
sister
are you ready yeah can we eat it yeah
they just want to eat
cake like they don't eat it
it's green
it's an ogre
congrats
oh do what you say she bought yellow
cake mix
turn it all green
oh
cause he mixed it with blue okay i got
that oh it's blue you're gonna have a
goblin child
[Laughter]
why are you crying
out of here
another brother no
damn
[Music]
that was it a little fart wow how much
do you think getting paid for that too
much too much
jesus christ
[Music]
it's white
we'll never know there's no way this
many gender
like they all fail apparently all of
them they just fail well they are they
they just are a failure if you do one
the end
plan agenda reveal
what is happening
who let my boyfriend play gender reveal
that's actually funny
it's probably the best gender reveal
party i've ever seen my boyfriend plan a
gender reveal
is that a cr oh okay you gotta get a
crane out for him well for the crane
well then sorry
there's actually a tv show in in uk
where they let the guy plan the
three
two
one
[Laughter]
you had one job
dude i bet you the people selling these
are just like yeah yeah right here you
go here's blue
it's gonna happen it'll be fine here we
go
oh my man right this guy looks excited
okay
oh soy boy can't
use the fork wow
[Laughter]
huge that was exciting
i had no idea this is that
commercialized that people all like they
yeah it's crazy
oh
it's a girl
he pulled out the balloon
why are they so close to it do they not
[Applause]
the child didn't suffer
[Applause]
yeah i got to see mom get smacked in the
face she had her mouth wide open
what is that
they just drove over some boxes three
[Music]
do they care do they actually care like
if there's a brother or sister oh i mean
they do care but i mean kids
they just get in their head what it's
gonna be and then this is like
disappointment when you're a villain
okay yeah
they're pink damn it another brother my
brother's so mean to me i want a little
brother
it's rocking me okay so they're doing
science okay yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
it hasn't registered with it boy
he's like i think
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah you should have done the science
better
we need more tests
let's send this back to the lab
damn kids are really i didn't realize
holy [ __ ] this is why they should be
butlers [ __ ] i'm not having
any of this [ __ ]
australian gender reveal party goes
wrong as car burst into flames
actually it wasn't wrong that's what
they wanted
jesus cried
australian police has released the
footage there it is so we're supposed to
do like a burnout
yeah it's a bar it's a
it's gonna be angie boy
oh dude
boy it was a thing oh god the whole
car's still going when the first time i
came to australia yeah it's been a
couple of years ago but we were driving
uh pretty far away from just kind of out
in the
bush right and there were just burnt
cars on the side of the road why
apparently it was a thing that people
would steal people's cars take them out
of the middle of nowhere and burn them
burn just burn
like burn people's cars
yeah just go and steal your car and burn
your house and go take it out in the
middle of nowhere and burn it well yeah
that's so weird what's wrong with people
yeah i don't know australians man uh the
classic one i mean this is where i first
heard about it where the a family's
gender reveal caused a large wildfire in
california like this blows my [ __ ]
mind you don't remember this huge
wildfire that happened it was crazy so
that whole huge one was from an actual
baby gender that seems like unbelievable
like i don't 7000 acres burned
oh my god i've been in l.a and you see
like this giant hills just being
completely burnt out and they were like
yeah they happened this is fire i'm like
what
yeah crazy they happen and this is what
like gave baby
or gender reveal party's like a bad name
like i mean they were already kind of
like weird anyway but yeah
then people started burning stuff and
like causing damage it's like okay but
everyone knows like don't use fire in
dry land like it shouldn't be that
difficult to figure that out
whether your baby has a penis or vagina
it's not that big you know chill out a
little bit you don't get to burn the
woods down oh man there's also this one
plane crashes
after unloading 350 gallons of pink
water engender reveals that pink water
and then the plane crashed he was killed
oh my god it gets worse people die i
hope i'm a woman killing gender reveal
party explosion what the [ __ ] did you
put in the explosion
you know little timmy your gender reveal
party kill grandma welcome the family
why are people out here using explosions
for random babies in the same sentence
[Music]
jesus christ
oh my gosh
are they gonna have like a fight see
which baby wins
only the strong baby gets to live oh
they're gonna fight
there she goes
what happens with the other baby
this is some weird jesus christ
why why why who thought of this
some people do with their money
three
two
one
no invincible pinata i've been here
before yeah
whoa
god
jesus christ leave the child out of this
[Music]
i know that [ __ ] kid's getting hurt yeah
you go
stop
stop look at that mom she know exactly
what she's doing why must the children
suffer
are you telling me people are allowed to
have kids for they can't tell up from
down
they usually have the most kids
they can't read what an arrow points
towards
the moment my sister led the pumpkin to
our legion during the she tried to keep
me from seeing
[Music]
i'm pretty sure they're going to see it
okay she's there that's funny
it's a red child
oh yeah blame basis
[ __ ]
how could he do dude
the panic i love the panicking people
it's like someone died or something he's
like it's gonna be okay
i had one job and i let everyone down
all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
that child will grow up to become
something great
you go you go to the gender reveal store
and they're like all right what do you
want the baby's fighting
the ball crush
the wrong color like let us know which
package
your kids suffered you know
we got it all how do you want to hurt
your child let us know and we'll set you
up wow that's gender reveal fails it's
fun watching that with you ken for the
first time together
yeah first time i've ever seen either
awesome thank you for showing me
check out ken uh for more gender reveal
videos
but you should wait a week so you don't
see the same videos
[Laughter]